- All right.
Y'all we are back.
And I don't know if you
were watching the show
yesterday when "America's Got Talent" Judge
Howie Mandel was on, but
it was just hilarious
from the moment he walked
out, and we never shut up.
So, he was here to tell
us about his new show,
bull word I can't say on daytime,
the game show on Netflix.
We even played a version,
but we talked so much
that we couldn't fit this
game into yesterday's hour.
So we are bringing it
to you today, and you're
welcome in advance.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] We thought we'd do a daytime
TV version called "Full of Bull."
- ♪ Full of bull ♪ (beep) ♪
- It's me against Howie.
So we need a host, as you said.
So could you give us a hand, Lord?
- [God] You know, I can Kelly.
How you doing Howie?
- It's not Morgan. Is it Morgan?
- [God] Well for legal
reasons, no, it's not,
but here's how it works.
I'm gonna give each of
you a multiple choice
question one at a time.
Now you will answer your question,
and then you're gonna
do your best to convince
the other person that you know
what you're talking about.
- Right
- [God] The other person will say
if they believe you, or
if they think you are
full of BS, which stands
for Blake Shelton, by the
way, that's what BS means.
- Which is the same definition.
- [God] Same exact thing.
Look it up in the dictionary,
there's Blake's face.
- No, but you should say the truth is
that you gotta answer the question.
If you know the answer,
you should know the ...
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [God] That's right.
- Go for the right answer.
- [Kelly] Okay
- Don't go for the bull.
Go for the right answer.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [God] Okay, Howie, God's talking now,
so let's pipe down, okay.
We're going into hour five
here, let's all calm down.
Okay, now listen.
If you correctly call the other person out
or you'll say the other
person is correct when
they are correct, you're
going to get a point.
Okay, let's go. Let's play this game.
- [Howie] All right.
- Okay. Okay.
- [God] Now, Howie.
- What God?
- [God] This first question is for you.
- Other people hear
this voice, too, right?
(crowd laughing)
Not just going on in my head.
- [God] It's only you,
Howie, it's only you.
- We're gonna cut it
out so you look crazy.
- So I look like an idiot,
just talking to myself.
- Okay, God.
- Yes. Okay, God, I hear you. He's coming.
- [God] Don't let them know,
Howie, the meds are working.
The meds are working.
Okay. First question is for
you, Howie, and your pants.
Here we go.
Mike Tyson has admitted
that he passed a drug test
by using a prosthetic
penis device called what?
Is it, A, the phony baloney?
B, the hoodwinker? or C, the whizzinator?
Howie, what's your answer?
- [Howie] So this is, okay,
Can I just say something?
So you, I'm pointing at your
- Alex
- at your producers
- Executive producer, yeah
- So this is not how you play the game
because you should . . . no, no
because they did research and
then it doesn't make it fun.
So I can't
- Wait, it doesn't make it fun?
Is this a real thing though?
- Yeah, so it's a hoodwinker,
and the reason I know it's a hoodwinker
and I'll tell you why.
- Okay.
- Because you did
research, you did research.
It's a little tube that you can pee in.
And the reason I know,
if you go Google me,
that I got caught with one
because I don't like
using public restrooms.
So I bought one
- A hoodwinker?
- I bought a hoodwinker to relieve myself.
You don't know, this might be bull (beep).
I'm wearing one now.
No, no, because this game goes on forever.
This show. And I didn't know.
I figured I wouldn't have time to go.
So hang on. Just gimme a second.
Ooh, all right, all right.
- [Kelly] Relief?
- I'm done. I've just pampered myself.
If you know what I mean.
- I think that you're
so good that that's BS.
I think that's BS.
- [Producer] That's right
- Oh my god!
- [God] That is correct.
- I think you're so good.
- I was trying to
hoodwink you. What is it?
- [God] Howie said it was the hoodwinker,
but it was actually C, the whizzinator.
- [Kelly] The whizzinator!
- [Howie] There's a whizzinator?
- [Kelly] I love that this is real!
- [God] Which is also, I think,
the name of the new Terminator
movie at this point.
(laughter)
Okay, Kelly.
- [Howie] You're in trouble.
- [God] Here you go.
Now this is for you, Kelly.
Now, if you don't know the
answer, you're gonna have to
fake it till you make it.
And you gotta make Howie
believe that you do, girl.
- I know facts. I know facts.
- [God] I think you got this one.
Okay. Here it is.
Considered one of history's
greatest innovations,
Archimedes' screw was designed to improve
what process?
- [Kelly] I know this one.
Was it A, irrigation?
B, printing? Or C, navigation?
- I actually know this
one, because no joke,
my uncle actually did - he
put in irrigation systems.
It's the one with irrigation.
It's the, what is it?
Irrigation.
- The one with irrigation.
- [Kelly] It's the one with the sprinkler.
It's the sprinkler thing.
The (noises imitating
a sprinkler shifting)
It's that thing.
- [Howie] Are we playing charades too?
It's bull (beep) mixed with charades.
- No, but I'm telling
you, it's irrigation.
- I think that you're
actually telling me the truth.
- I am telling you the truth.
It is irrigation.
- No bull (beep)
I, I was right.
So I get
- [God] That is correct. That is correct.
Kelly was telling the truth.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- [God] All right, now Howie, over to you.
Here's your question.
- Okay.
- [God] Many historians agree.
Oh, by the way, this is the
last one, I've been informed.
- [Howie] This is already bull (beep)
- [God] Season five, right now.
- [Howie] Historians don't get together.
- [God] That's right.
That's exactly right. Okay.
- Many historians agree.
- [Kelly] Many historians,
all of them at a club.
- Yeah, have you ever been in a room,
oh, there's only historians in here!
They're all agreeing.
Everybody seems to be getting along.
- [God] All right. This is your final.
- They're agreeing!
- [God] The final question, here it is.
- We got it, we got it.
I know! Just tell me the question!
- [God] Many historians agree that
the domino effect that led
to the outbreak of World War One
was set in motion by
what innocent mistake?
Was it A, a letter
getting lost in the mail?
- [Howie] No.
- [God] A car making a wrong turn?
- [Howie] Yeah.
- [God] Or a painting being damaged?
Howie, what's your answer and why?
- I do know this cuz I know history.
- Hmm.
- I know this it's the
car going the wrong way.
- [Kelly] What?
- Down the street. I just know my history.
It is the car going.
You're looking at like
I don't - you're smiling
like, "oh, he doesn't know
what he's talking about."
Well, lady, you are gonna be surprised.
I know exactly what I'm talking about.
It's a car going the
wrong way. I do know that.
I do know that.
- [God] Now, Kelly, does he
know that? Or is he BSing?
- I do know that.
- [God] You keep saying it.
- I, I know that.
- I feel like it's just the wrong answer
- Then I wouldn't know that.
So you're saying I'm bull (beep).
- I think you're bull (beep).
- [God] Well, I'm sorry, Kelly.
That's unfortunate because
he was telling the truth.
- I do know that.
- I thought it would be the letter!
- [God] He said it was the
car making a wrong turn.
- [Howie] You think a letter
would start a whole world war?
- [Kelly] You think a car
making a wrong turn?!?
- [Howie] Yeah.
I was in that room with the historians.
We all agreed, but let's not
invite Kelly to this party.
- I thought it would be that
letter getting lost, you know?
- [Howie] I guess you didn't get it.
You didn't know it.
I told you I knew it.
You don't listen to me.
- [Kelly] I didn't, I didn't believe you.
There's a difference.
I heard you.
I didn't believe you.
- [God] Well, guess what?
That means everybody's going
home with a whizzinator
because Howie is the winner!
A shock to no one.
- Okay. Good game, Howie! Thank you, Lord!
- [God] Thank you.